jimmy kimmel the other day
allegedly a comedian is he a comedian he
used to be sort of a comedian jimmy
kimmel now who's hosting one of the
lower rated late night talk shows
came out
and he said that the people who refused
to get the fouchy algae the people who
refuse to get this hastily developed
drug against the wuhan cough
they do not deserve to be treated at
hospitals dr fauci said that if
hospitals get any more overcrowded
they're going to have to make some very
tough choices about who gets an icu bet
that choice doesn't seem so tough to me
vaccinated person having a heart attack
yes come right on in we'll take care of
you unvaccinated guy who gobbled horse
goo rest in peace wheezy you're
we've still got a lot of
pandemics out there people are still
taking this ivermectin this pois you
know the poison control centers have
seen as this spike in calls from people
taking this livestock medicine to fight
the coronavirus but they won't take the
vaccine which is crazy if you're a vegan
and you're like no i don't want a
hamburger give me that can of alpo
instead
so first of all as as we covered on the
show last week ivermectin is not a horse
drug any more than aspirin is a horse
drug ivermectin is a drug approved by
the fda for use in humans called a
wonder drug by many many people you can
find a lot of studies about it from the
national institutes of health you can
hear wonderful things said about it
everywhere from the cdc to webmd it was
only because some conservatives pointed
out huh maybe we should start focusing
on therapeutics to treat this virus
rather than focusing on a vaccine that
appears to be less effective than you
all promised us it would be
only then did they say it's a it's horse
goo
ha ha you dummies take the vaccine which
is totally 100 safe except the teenage
boys are 6.1 times as likely to suffer
heart problems from the vaccine as they
are to face hospitalization from the
virus there was another study from the
science that came out just a couple of
days ago but hahaha you you unvexed
people don't deserve a hospital bed
hey gay guy you don't deserve a hospital
bed if you get aids hey fat guy you
don't deserve a hospital bed if you come
down with a heart condition or diabetes
hey smoker you don't deserve a hospital
bed if you get cancer hey
including pot smokers by the way i know
now it's easy to ostracize tobacco
smokers because that's politically
incorrect what about the pot smokers hey
you can't nope sorry you can't is that
how we're going to
conduct medicine because in that case no
one's going to get treated for anything
because people
generally speaking
suffer from medical conditions because
of their lifestyle because of their
environments that they find themselves
in they
some of it is just born out of nature
but a lot of it comes from the way that
we live our lives
but no
everyone else who makes
choices gets to be treated
just not conservatives because we don't
score high enough on the social credit
score i'm so glad that you enjoyed that
clip i want you to enjoy the whole show
so head on over to
the michael knowles show at apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
head up before you go vote again in
california i assume you've already voted
once before someone voted for you
but before you go do it again subscribe
to the michael knowles show we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you